I'd like to start by asking you guys to
do some whoo who here has a little bit
of anxiety or has had some anxiety
before presented by show of hands and
who here is presenting today if you keep
your hands up okay great so I'd actually
like to have you engaged in something
with me so for a moment if you don't
want to put down your laptop's and I
want you to suspend disbelief for just
one moment we're gonna do a breathing
exercise where what I'd like you to do
is on the breath in through your nose
you say I am silent to your ship
silently to yourself and as you exhale
you stay relaxed so it's all do it one
one time ready I am breathing breathe
out relax one more time I am relaxed now
I know what you're thinking here but
this is crazy but scientific evidence
actually shows that our brains don't
know how to tell the difference between
what is actually happening to us and
what we imagine so therefore we have the
power through our minds through our
thoughts as well as to our behaviors to
actually control the way we feel and
through that religion control biological
responses to stress so today what we're
going to do is we're going to introduce
a series of techniques to actually go
about controlling your mind and your
body to manipulate these biological
responses to stress
so we have a quick agenda and what we'd
like to do is talk about this in terms
of how to manage the mind and how to
manage the body we're going to offer a
buffet technique today what we want to
do is we want to offer some that will
take some practice and some that are
immediately implementable today and what
we'd like to do with this is give you an
opportunity to try some of these out and
I encourage you to try some exotic
you're presenting today so with that
I'll hand it over to Patricia oh and
Olivia to start as well so the way that
we think about presentations with the
way that we approach them or frame them
in our minds significant complete
influences how nervous we are when
presenting in front of a colleague turns
out that many of us think about
presentations as performances such as
acting in when you're acting you're
given a certain set of lines that you
have to say exactly in a precise way in
a precise time the precise place this
means that there's a right way and a
wrong way to act this leads to actors
feeling fear that they might not be
saying things in the right way and
ultimately leads to performance excited
so we as presenters if we frame our
presentations like performances we might
have some of this fear creeping in what
I want to just what I want to suggest to
you is that instead we reframe
presentations as conversations and this
is great because normally people are not
nervous about having a conversation
whereas we may be nervous about
performing so but it's also great
because presentations are more like
conversations of their performances to
begin with there is no right or wrong
way you don't have to adhere to a
certain script there may be a better way
to communicate things but ultimately you
have some flexibility the other reason
why presentations are more like
conversations is that it's actually a
dialogue in a conversation so it's not
just you in front of an audience in the
spotlight it's you engaging with your
audience and receiving feedback from
them even though it may not be verbal so
I want to leave you with is three things
that you can start doing to make your
presentations more conversational the
first one is do an outline don't
memorize your speech practice each chunk
of the outline and it doesn't matter
that does have to be perfect or exactly
the same each time the second thing I
want to recommend is practice
conversationally instead of standing in
front of the mirror or in front of a
camera sit down if you can with a friend
and talk to your presentation the third
one is interact with your audience you
can do this by asking questions
taking polls using the word you a lot
and even using the names in your
audience if you can so these three
things will help you make your
presentations more conversational and
will help you take away some of that
anxiety with that I'll hand it over to
Olivia
so Patricia's talk to you about
reframing presentations as conversations
I'm now going to talk about reframing
anxiety itself what do you do if you
feel anxious and just can't help it
one great way to deal with this is just
to recognize that what you're feeling is
completely normal you can say to
yourself oh here are those anxious
feelings again now I found personally
that this takes some practice
and then in fact it'll be several
presentations before just recognizing
that you are feeling anxious is enough
to make you stop feeling anxious so I'm
going to add to the buffet of techniques
that we are presenting to you today by
talking about some specific quick fixes
that come from recognizing that anxiety
is of based on natural biological and
evolutionary response so here you'll see
a hormone this hormone is oxytocin and
it's incredibly powerful it's talked
about in some of the sort of public
literature and particularly in the
popular press as being the love hormone
and more recently research has shown
that it in fact can help to reduce
levels of adrenaline and cortisol and
stress so how do you go about generating
this magical hormone one way is to turn
to a friend and hug them may not always
be appropriate to do that before you go
into a presentation so an alternative is
just to find a supportive audience
member walk over to them and shake their
hand before they start again that might
not work in every situation so going
with the buffet of techniques in
addition to just being able to hug it
out which may not always work we'd say
that you should also recognize that even
Lucia Murray our behavior has led to its
filling these feelings of stress prior
to presentations and that it's actually
an adaptive behavior that you feel that
you're anxious about your status in the
group how will people perceive you this
is partly because the human mind
concentrate on the future rather than
thinking about the present
so a further technique that you can use
is to engage in what is known as flow
activities these flow activities can be
things like doing one thing that's been
suggested is 100 press-ups before you go
on which is a bit much for me frankly so
you might go outside the room in my case
and try and sing you might play a game
on your computer find something humorous
to watch alternatively
I would ask you to support to say with
me this Limerick so I'll count us in two
three and the idea of this technique is
that you have to focus on what you're
saying so much that you can't actually
worry about what's coming next
so one two three I slid oh shoot Chito
slow and on that slitted sheet I sit and
repeat and with that I'll hand over to
some of the more physical sites of
managing your anxiety thank you thank
you until you become it what what are we
faking there's strong evidence that your
body can change your mind the way you
pose projects a certain image and if you
project power you can feel more powerful
and you can use this feeling of power to
become more confident before your
presentation so how does this work let's
just do a little experiment you're
sitting down at the moment I've just
leaned forward a little bit put your
elbows on your legs put your right hand
on your left knee your left hand on your
right knee and say I'm confident he's a
bit unnatural doesn't it now stand up
extend your arms make yourself as big as
you can and say I am confident it
doesn't this feel much more natural
this is the difference between a high
power chorus and the low power curves
and if you engage in high power poses
before your presentation you can feel a
lot more confident during the
presentation scientifically how does
this work posing in a high power way
makes your testosterone level goes up
testosterone is a hormone that is linked
to dominance and masculinity at the same
time posing in a high-power way as
opposed to a low power way makes your
cortisol level Goes Down which uncoated
as a stress hormone so you feel a lot
less stressed so I encourage all of you
before your presentation fake it until
you become it all right for last couple
techniques I like to talk about
diaphragmatic breathing or more
informally known as belly breathing and
so what does this mean how do how does
this actually help well by doing this
type of breathing we can actually
stimulate our parasympathetic nervous
system from our sympathetic and that
means that we go from the
fight-or-flight mode into the rest or
digest mode so what this does it
actually relaxes your muscles allows
oxygen to flow more fully through your
body and we can actually physically not
be in a stress state by breathing this
way so that's pretty powerful so quickly
I'd like to go through and actually
teach you how to do this type of
breathing diaphragmatic breathing so
what we're going to do is we're going to
breathe in through our nose we're going
to hold it for a count of four we're
going to gently hold that breath for
seven and then we're going to release it
through the mouth for count of eight and
the tip would be is feel like you're
breathing in all the room in the air and
when you exhale your stomach should
literally feel like it's tighten at the
end so maybe put your hand on your
stomach to let it release out they give
yourself like a baby that's how babies
breathe that's how animals breathe so
let's try one of these so breathe in
slowly count to four
hold it for seven and now exhale through
the mouth
audibly if you like that's one breath if
you're able to do three of those before
any presentation your body will actually
feel calmer it's just the natural
biological response now we only have a
couple more minutes but I want to also
introduce one technique which is about
mindfulness bringing your presence to to
the current moment and if through that
being able to actually reset it yourself
this is sort of an idea of
non-judgmental awareness and this is key
to actually reducing stress and bringing
a state of calm so what you can do with
this 5 4 3 2 1 technique is you name
five things that you see and then five
things that you hear then you go again
and you do it with four things that you
see and four things that you hear and as
you go closer to one you'll recognize
that those intrusive thoughts those
feelings anxiety will all just melt away
with that I'd like to tell you please
try these out and let us know what you
think we'd love to hear more from you
and see which one's work and which ones
don't
any questions